on va parler d'immigration Hervé
Marseille puisque mardi prochain une
semaine après les députés les sénateurs
vont débattre de la question migratoire
et notamment du projet loi immigration
que le gouvernement est en train de
préparer un texte qui prévoit
d'accélérer les procédures d'expulsion
de régulariser les travailleurs sans
papier et de créer un titre de séjour
pour les métiers en tension alors ce
projet de loi pour l'instant la droite
sénatoriale est contre on va écouter
Bruno Retailleau le président du groupe
les républicains au Sénat la loi sur
l'immigration c'est non pourquoi
pour plein de raisons puisque il s'agit
pas de contrôler l'immigration massive
il s'agit au contraire d'ouvrir un peu
plus les vannes je vous démontre comment
François Hollande a déjà supprimé le
délit de séjour illégal pour les
clandestins en 2012 et là en réalité on
va un peu plus loin c'est-à-dire que on
annonce que un clandestin arrivé sur le
sol français sera régularisé
automatiquement deuxième chose il y a un
deuxième guichet pour les déboutés du
droit d'Asie ils seront que si on les
refuse en termes de statut de réfugiés
ils auront droit à un second guichet qui
sera
on voit bien que la difficulté on essaie
de faire pression en disant tant que
vous reprenez pas vos gens qui posent
problème en France nous on vous donne
plus de visa et ben il rigole et il
passe par l'Espagne qui elle donne les
visas et voilà donc il faut surtout
trouver des solutions européennes alors
au niveau du gouvernement le
gouvernement français a cette idée de
proposer un titre de séjour métier en
tension dans les secteurs qui peinent à
recruter pour vous c'est une bonne idée
pourquoi pas ça se discute ce sont les
patrons eux-mêmes qu'ils demandent et on
sait tous qu'il y a des métiers en
tension on sait tous qui a un tas de
gens qui travaillent dans des conditions
précaires sans papiers que ça soit dans
la restauration ou dans certaines
industries notamment touristiques et et
on fait semblant de ne pas regarder ce
qui se passe il y a une forme de logique
après il faut encadrer tout ça il faut
regarder comment ça peut marcher il faut
être pragmatique parce que si c'est
simplement pour dire écoutez on va
renvoyer les gens chez eux on laisse
plus passer personne et puis on peut pas
accepter les régularisations
écoutez on sait très bien que ça marche
pas on sait très bien que c'est pas la
réalité des choses je crois qu'il y a un
vrai débat européen qui doit être mené
puisque il y a un pacte d'immigration
qui était lancé en 2020 qui pour
l'instant patine entre temps il y a des
dispositifs de solidarité qui ont été
mis en place c'est compliqué on voit
bien avec nos amis italiens sont
toujours les mêmes qui accueillent
c'est-à-dire la France l'Italie
l'Espagne parce que c'est le sud et puis
on dit aux autres et ben on va partager
vous allez prendre oui mais pourquoi
croyez-vous que Madame Meloni a été élu
parce que les Italiens ils en ont un peu
un peu assez de d'accueillir toute la
misère du monde et à chaque fois on
inventait un truc formidable qui
s'appelle la dublinisation les accords
de Dublin c'est à dire que quand on
attrape quelqu'un sur le sol européen
par exemple à Calais on dit par où es-tu
arrivé il dit par Lampedusa on le
renvoie à Vintimille en lui disant bonne
chance tu verras c'est formidable Italie
donc ça peut pas marcher il faut trouver
des solutions collectives et moi je dis
il faut qu'on en parle on peut pas
rejeter un texte d'emblée on sait que
c'est compliqué et donc nous on va
examiner avec un avis plutôt favorable
ce texte mais est-ce que cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier ça ne va pas créer un appel d'air
migratoire c'est en tout cas ce que dit
la droite et rassemblement national oui
mais moi je veux bien qu'on court à
droite toutes à chaque fois qu'on parle
de domaine régalien il y a quelqu'un qui
est formidable et qui réussit à tous les
coups dans ce domaine c'est Madame Le
Pen
s'il y en a une qui récupérera c'est
elle donc je crois que quand on dit
qu'on est des parties de gouvernement
qu'un jour on a vocation à retourner au
gouvernement de ce pays on essaie
d'avoir des attitudes et des
propositions qui soient réalistes et
dont on pourrait s'inspirer le jour où
on est en responsabilité si c'est pour
dire la même chose que Madame Le Pen ou
que monsieur Zemmour c'est pas la peine
de se fatiguer il y a déjà les recettes
donc là les LR cours un petit peu après
Madame Le Pen sur l'immigration je sais
pas ce qu'ils font c'est à eux de
décider mais en tous les cas ils seront
jamais meilleurs que ces deux là
[Musique]